oh écoutez on va tout mettre en oeuvre
en tout cas pour que l'on puisse
fonctionner dans le cadre d'un projet
qui aujourd'hui va quoi répondre aux
bisontins et horizons qui n'est même
plus largement à la communauté urbaine
quand vous abordez une ville
historiquement à gauche je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le grand des vannes nous
a montré que les clivages politiques
étaient quasiment fine même s'il ya des
philosophies qui peuvent qui peuvent
rester par rapport à cela
mais aujourd'hui l'idée c'est vraiment
de co construire une communauté de
projets pour répondre aux besoins des
des bisontins et et puis surtout
répondre d'un côté hague matic alors sa
tombe c'est une liste les républicains
où c'est plus large que ça écoutez vous
l'avez vu je parle dans le cas de la
conférence de presse on va au delà même
si on n'a pas à se renier parce qu'on
sait aussi de quelle famille politique
nous venons mais il est important
aujourd'hui de pouvoir travailler avec
l'ensemble des personnalités de la
société civile d'autre six personnes
d'autres familles politiques
courard répondre à une vraie attente ya
un vrai besoin sur le territoire
bisontin suite des choses que les
personnes peuvent attendre
on parlait tout à l'heure dans le cas de
la conférence de presse sur l'accueil de
tous les enfants on encadre la cantine
scolaire
c'est pas une problématique du gauche et
mal
deloitte collégiale et on apportera des
réponses qu'on appelait déjà les
apporter au sein du conseil municipal
écoutez ça c'est un travail qu'on a mené
conjointement avec avec jacques perrin
jacques grosperrin sénateurs souhaitent
dans le cadre du non cumul des mandats
bien sûr continuer son travail sur le
territoire du doubs qui fait de façon
remarquable et il m'a demandé donc de
pouvoir porter et emmener ses fils de
besançon maintenant sur le territoire
bisontin nous travaillons depuis très
longtemps avec jacques grosperrin dans
cette danse et freddie mac dynamique de
déco partage de co construction et c'est
tout naturellement que j'ai répondu
favorablement parce qu'on a aussi cette
expérience aujourd'hui qui en tant que
conseiller municipal entend qu'un
respect en du département me permet de
mieux appréhender les éléments donc du
territoire et d'avoir vraiment une
installation dans les dossiers dans le
suivi des dossiers
donc il faut savoir aussi rendre les
éléments quand ils viennent et on a une
vraie ambition pour le territoire
collégialement
non non on a vous savez avec jacques
avec jacques grosperrin ça fait plus de
vingt ans qu'on se connaît on travaille
en étroite collaboration et un moment
donné dans les échanges tout
naturellement il est venu vers moi en me
disant je pense qu'il faudrait que tu
puisse emmener cette liste pour pour
donner un nouveau souffle et une
nouvelle dynamique aux territoires
bisontin s'est pas fait petit hic a
fallu aussi réfléchir parce que c'est
aussi mon gré une vraie charge à pouvoir
emmener tout cela il faut pouvoir peser
et faire preuve de discernement et on
s'est revus et tout naturellement donc
j'ai accepté sa proposition et je l'en
remercie aussi de la confiance qu'ils me
témoignent